the stories these directors brought to
the screen are as varied as the nominees
themselves whether American or foreign
born whether oscar-winning legends or
first-timers whether bringing to the
screen a fantasy a tragic love story a
magical surreal world romantic comedy or
a slice of history their shared
characteristic is their monumental and
profound talent here are the nominees
for achievement in directing mikail
Chanukah a war then citing feasts of the
Sun hey life is pain Stephen speak
David O'Russell silver miles
and the Oscar goes to Angley
for Life of Pi this is the
thank you
thank you so much
Thank You movie god I really need to
share this with all 3000 everybody
worked with me in Life of Pi I want to
thank you for I really want to thank you
for believing this story and share this
incredible journey with me
I need to thank ya Martell for writing
this incredible inspiring book everyone
at Fox thank you for taking the leap
with me especially Tom Rocklin
Jim Jim monopolist and Elizabeth Gabler
my producers guild later David warm up
David Lee one of our cast
sewage where are you you're a miracle is
playing a young pie carrying the movie
every one of you in the cast I cannot
waste this time talking about them I
really held your the golden statue in my
heart I cannot make this movie without
the help of Taiwan we shout there I want
to thank everybody there helped us
especially the city of taichung my
Indian crew I love you my Canadian crew
I love you my family in Taiwan my wife
Jen Lin will be married 30 years this
summer I love you my boys Hana Mason
thank you for your support
finally my my agent Karen sage and
lawyer arrastra codepal oh I have to do
that
especially for this movie it's great to
have your support Thank You Academy
share namaste